bien mais il était 18h30 7 précise
souvenez vous merci de bien vouloir
éteindre votre téléphone
et si c'est difficile merci de les
mettre en mode avion moi je m'en
souviens encore
deux heures sans son portable deux
heures c'est inhumain
moi je pense sincèrement chez tedx ils
viennent d'une autre planète se rendent
pas compte se rendent pas compte
bon maintenant ça aurait pu être pire ça
aurait pu être pire ils auraient pu nous
demander de sortir le téléphone de les
déverrouiller et de les passer à nos
voisins dans la salle en leur disant
jouer avec hommes voulaient pendant cinq
minutes
et oui je vous ai dit ça aurait pu être
pire
en fait nos téléphones sont de
véritables du doubs on ne partage pas on
ne le portent sur soi toute la journée
on le tapote gentiment pour le réveiller
régulièrement et le soir on s'inquiète
même de son niveau d'énergie et du coup
on lallange délicatement pour
l'alimenter dans un petit coin de
véritables du doubs mais tout ça c'est
ccc faisant en même temps c'est pesant
parce que au fond du fond quand on est
sur nos portables
on se transforme en zombie en fait on
vient des zombies du smartphone alors ça
porte un nom laisse mon by smartphone
zombies et ses envies partout on nous
envie
voilà alors cette affaire c'est pas tout
à fait notre faute
1 ce n'est pas que de notre faute en
fait les applications et le contenu de
nos téléphones sont conçus sont pensés
pour que nous passions un temps fou sur
nos téléphones
ça s'appelle addictives design est un ex
google tristan harris explique très bien
comment les grands acteurs d'internet
les grands acteurs du web conçoivent ses
applications pour nous faire passer un
temps fou sur nos portables et en fait
ils s'inspirent même des machines les
plus addictives au monde pour qu'on
passe
encore plus de temps sur nos portables
sont les machines à sous des casinos
penser quand on est sur une page avec
des messages et qu'on veut rafraîchir la
page
qu'est ce qu'on fait on tire l'écran
vers le bas et on relâche exactement
comme la manette les machines à sous et
quand un nouveau message arrive on
entend ce doux tintement vous savez le
petit ring
exactement comme une pièce de monnaie
qui tourner la machine à sous et enfin
les messages d'ailleurs quand on les
reçoit
c'est pas une petite flèche à côté c'est
pas un petit très content rouve à côté
en fait c'est une pastille en forme de
pièces de monnaie tout ceci est
parfaitement pensé c'est parfaitement
étudiée alors cette addiction à notre
portable pose deux grands problèmes
le premier c'est qu'on se met
physiquement en danger
comme vous pouvez le voir ici bon
maintenant il y a d'ailleurs ça a donné
le jour à quelques solutions très
originales comme celle ci par exemple
voilà un panneau sinisation pour les
automobilistes pour leur indiquer qu'ils
vont entrer dans une zone à smoby ou
encore celle ci ou sur les trottoirs on
va séparer les smoby des autres piétons
c'est déjà déployé en belgique
ça arrive ça arrive en fait le deuxième
gros problème est encore plus profond
c'est qu'en passant notre temps tête
baissée sur un smartphone on se coupent
progressivement des autres et on se
coupent progressivement du monde qui
nous entoure en se coupent
progressivement des autres les ados et
les enfants se coupe
petit à petit leurs proches et
inversement il y en a mais il ya même
des gens qui s'occupent de la réalité et
on a d'autres qui se coupe littéralement
du monde et ça fait réfléchir
ce photo réelle alors que au fond du
fond nous sommes avant tout des êtres
sociaux
nous avons besoin d'interagir les uns
avec les autres
nous avons besoin d'un terreau jacques
les eaux une grande université
américaine université de harvard a lancé
une étude depuis 80 ans depuis 80 ans et
cette étude a montré que les personnes
qui avaient les relations de qualité les
plus poussées avec leurs proches avec
leurs amis avec leur entourage étaient
celles qui étaient les plus heureuses et
qui était en meilleure santé et ses
interactions dans la vraie vie avec les
autres nous permettent trois choses la
première c'est qu'elle nous permette de
construire notre personnalité
on va garder retenir ce qu'on aime bien
chez les autres et laisser ce qu'on aime
moins
la deuxième chose c'est que ces
interactions avec les autres dans la vie
réelle permettent à notre cerveau de se
construire et de se développer
physiologiquement ça a été démontré par
les nouveaux films physique
physiologiste et enfin bien sûr ces
interactions de la vie réelle nous font
vivre des moments intenses un sourire
échangé quelques mots à la volée et puis
voilà des sensations qu'ils nous
prennent on est touchés on est intrigué
on est ému et ça ce n'est possible
que dans la vraie vie mais aussi nous
sommes des explorateurs né nous avons
besoin d'interagir avec le monde nous
allons le monde qui nous entoure
donc résumons nous d'un côté nous avons
nous passons notre temps tête baissée
sur nos téléphones et d'un autre côté
nous l'avons démontré nous avons un
besoin quasi vital d'explorer le monde
autour de nous mais aussi d'interagir
avec les autres autour de nous alors
certains ont trouvé une solution ce sont
les très fortunés
est-ce que paradoxalement alors que chez
la plupart des gens les téléphones
prolifèrent les écrans prolifèrent et
bien chez les très fortunés celle
inverse est de moins en moins d'écrans
et ils envoient leurs familles pardon
ils envoient leurs enfants dans des
écoles où tout est fondé sur les livres
sur les sensations tactiles et sur les
interactions humaines
alors moi moi j'ai cru que c'était la
solution je me suis dit plus d'écrans
plus de téléphone et mes deux garçons
m'ont assez vite ramenés à la réalité
alors maintenant on peut se poser la
question et si le téléphone nous
permettait de relever la tête de notre
portable
ah oui puisque après tout après tout si
on le regarde sous un angle différent
cet objet là il est doté d'outils très
puissants dont certains peuvent nous
amener à relever la tête du téléphone
prenons quelques exemples vous souvenez
de ce moment vous êtes quelque part dans
peut-être dans un café dans une soirée
où même dans une voiture écouter la
radio et tout d'un coup vous écouter une
musique ce morceau vous plaît énormément
vous le connaissez pas vous avez envie
d'en savoir plus mais il existe des
applis outils qui permettent en un clic
de vous en dire plus sur le morceau
musique donc là en l'occurrence ce
téléphone m'a permis d'explorer plus
avant mon environnement sonore
autre exemple lorsque vous avez envie de
vous rendre quelque part comme c'était
mon cas cet après midi et que je ne
connais pas
le lieu de destination c'est la première
fois que j'y vais et bien il y a il
existe des applis outil bien connu qui
vont vous permettre non seulement de
trouver le chemin d'explorer le chemin
optimal mais aussi de visualiser à quoi
ressemble le lieu de destination
et enfin quand on se retrouve dans le
noir aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on fait on
t'a pop jusqu'à tomber sur le téléphone
etc et et en déclenche l'application
outil magique à lampe torche qui va
littéralement nous permettre de
retrouver où nous en sommes dans notre
environnement proche notre environnement
physique
voilà autant d'applications outils qui
nous permettent d'explorer notre
environnement nous reconnecter à notre
environnement
deux exemples maintenant d'applications
outils qui permettent elles de se
reconnecter aux autres de se connecter
aux autres autour de nous imaginer cette
situation vous êtes dans une file
d'attenté un festival un concert un
resto u ou même un starbucks vous
commencez à vous engager la conversation
avec la personne qui à côté de vous vous
échangé quelques mots sympathiques et au
bout d'un moment vous dit ce serait
sympa garder le contact
il existe des applications outils
aujourd'hui qui vous permette en un clic
sans et changer de numéro
sans s'inscrire sur un site quelconque
de garder le contact
voilà un cas de figure où cette mon
portable a permis de prolonger une
interaction dans dans la vie réelle
autre exemple celle ci qui est aussi
frappante
imaginez maintenant vous soyez
malentendants et imaginez que vous
sortiez avec des amis ce soir là vous
êtes autour d'un dîner il existe des
applications outils il faut savoir parce
que quand on est malentendant c'est très
difficile de suivre ses amis dans un
dîner comme ça souvent on a tendance à
s'isoler et à jouer avec son jeu préféré
sur son téléphone
là il existe des applications outils
comme celle ci qui va permettre de
retranscrire sur son écran en temps réel
ce que chacun dit en précisant qui le
dit alors oui je suis d'accord et me
dire oui mais la personne a les yeux
rivés sur son téléphone pour suivre la
conversation
c'est vrai mais je vais dire que c'est
pour la bonne cause c'est pour être
d'autant mieux connecté avec les autres
lors du dîner
cette personne est totalement connecté à
son environnement à ce moment
6 alors comme on a pu le voir avec ces
quelques exemples il y à des
applications outils particulièrement
puissante dans ce dans ce téléphone il
suffit de regarder notre téléphone sous
un angle différent
alors samedi rue mais en pratique
comment on fait ça pour garder sous un
angle différent ça donne quoi
et ben moi ce que je vous propose c'est
que ça donne ça ah oui ça c'est un tout
autre angle
parce que l'idée c'est quoi l'idée c'est
que on a entre les mains tout de même un
doudou à deux visages un visage sur
lequel on a un écran dans lequel on peut
plonger des heures et un autre visage
qui finalement est un objet douter doter
d'outils très puissants que nous pouvons
actionner quand nous le décidons et aux
services d'expérience dans la vraie vie
donc au final cette affaire c'est par
cette petite astuce tu juste une petite
astuce mais se trouve que ça peut
changer la vie est bien et l'idée c'est
de pouvoir passer d'un mode selon biz a
plutôt un mode smarties
et c'est sympa l'isthme artiste un mode
smart isu mon téléphone est au service
de mes interactions dans la vraie vie je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]